je demande c'est ce quiz est aujourd'hui
équipée d'un parapluie pour vous parler
de la paris games week parce que oui je
serai présent à la paris games week avec
amine original et environ 46 millions
youtube heures donc qu'est-ce que la
paris games week déjà je me le demande
paris games week c'est là où tu peux
jouer à des jeux que tu as jamais vu ah
oui oui c'est vrai la sariat l'appareil
ainsi que bon je crois que savait tous
que c'est ça un petit rendez vous il y
aura pas mal d youtuber paraît d'abonnés
bon beaucoup de gens et beaucoup de jeux
à tester sur tout et je fais cette
petite vidéo pour vous dire que j'y
serai deux visages l'un à m'avoir
demandé si j'y serai j'irai le jeudi et
le samedi et le soir presse mais bon ça
on s'en fout et quoi qu'il en soit ça va
être sûrement bien vous pouvez me
reconnaître jeudi je suis rhabillé
normale et samedi je vous ferai une
petite surprise
attention ghana où tu vas mourir tout
simplement bas et j'ai envie de dire
qu'est ce que tu leur donne rendez vous
à tous toutes ces personnes je leur
donne rendez vous évidemment l'appareil
logique binaire on va être pas mal à se
croiser et ça c'est clair et net
ce qui va se passer aussi c'est dur a
beaucoup de youtube heures donc on
essaiera peut-être déformé à un petit
groupe signé avec to you tube heures et
tous les abonnés on essaiera de faire
tout ça là bas on vous verra bien sur
place en tout cas n'hésitez pas si vous
me reconnaissez ou si vous reconnaissez
des youtuber a foncé est allé les voir
et à faire moi je te connais pas tort ça
serait vraiment génial
et attention ça tombait j'aimais le
stress au caméraman et puis voilà alors
c'est un petit mois jeudi sur la paille
hamsik [ __ ] moi je dis tout comme toi
je donne rendez vous à tous les youtube
heures qui on regarde la vidéo est bon
bah c'est pas grave c'est le direct
attention je donne rendez vous aux
encore une fois à temps à tous les
outils leurs idées moi
rendez vous à tous les chauffeurs à tous
les abonnés l'équipe originale sera là
pour faire des vidéos et tout simplement
je remercie squeeze vas-y vas-y film
allez je le dirai je fis voilà tout ça
pour vous dire que j'allais paris games
week avec beaucoup de tubes heures et
beaucoup d'autres abonnés et que ça va
être vraiment quelque chose de
sympathique alors allez-y si vous voulez
avoir du fun et tout ça il ya un mec
bizarre derrière nous pas nous suivre
et puis voilà en tout cas puissante
mieux passer voir la sienne à aménager
note si vous avez envie
s'il ya une petite hésitation c'est ma
description et c'est lui qui m'a
interviewé avec son équipe c'est super
cool
à bientôt tout le monde paie sa route
n'est gaz je te remercions sérieusement
je tends
les moments chauds de squeeze n'achetez
pas être chose de ridicule en plus ça
fait le carton connaissez-vous
l'instrument un final du monde
houari
utilité jo a commencé comme ça